blood à une inscription cette casquette
significatif du sang qui a coulé ici à
place d'armes au lamentin le du dernier
après le carnaval se lamente hinault le
26 ans circulait à moto
ils ont été poursuivis par ses
agresseurs il semble qu'il doit perdu le
contrôle de son engin qui s'encastrent
de la clôture de cette maison les
occupants sont dérangés par un but
surprenant
j'ai entendu un gros bruit c'est tout
cela j'ai entendu que j'ai même pensé
que c'est une porte que j'ai embarqué
cadets frappé aussi fort mais je n'ai
rien entendu doute au magic avec des
coûts de fait mais j'ai pas entendu
d'occuper seulement le bonhomme est et
en baisser au mahb arrière et voilà et
vu la barrière et guy mottin en arrêt
cardio vasculaires malgré les tentatives
des secours le décès de david et déclaré
sur place les premières constatations
conclu à un banal accident de la
circulation
mais ce rebondissement surprenant
intervient dans la cause du décès de cet
homme qui réside au quartier demandent
plutôt un médecin découvre deux balles
dans le corps de david myrtil une
enquête est aussitôt diligentée par le
parquet de fort-de-france sa tante nous
donne une version des faits
d'après l'un dire il était l'âme attaque
ses amis dont il a dit qu'il rentrait
chez lui et c'est de là qu'il a eue
poursuite la possibilité voilà c'est
comme ça s'est passé ça passe
il semblerait que le bijou de la victime
aurait été dérobé le soir du drame et
mes photos des bijoux sa chaîne sayabec
depuis des boucles d'oreilles c'est tout
vous avouer je pense faire ça parce
qu'on a retrouvé la mère et les scores
de david encore sous le choc ont du mal
à s'exprimer
in quitté cgt
david bien qu'il venait tout juste de
terminer un contrat au service des
espaces verts la mutualité du lamentin
le ou les agresseurs sont toujours
recherchés
l'enquêté confiée à la police judiciaire
afin de déterminer les circonstances
précises de cet homicide